welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David today David is out
at a speaking engagement so far today
we've talked a little about Donald Trump
but I think we need to move a little
into the Republican Party as a whole
when you look at the Republican Party
platform when you hear a Republican
running for really any office it doesn't
matter if it's a local office a state
office or a federal office
you kind of get one theme going with the
entire Republican Party and this has
been their theme since at least the
1980s for my entire life that theme is
we got to cut regulations to a lesser
extent we got to cut taxes but we'll get
into that more in just a minute but
regulations those those Bugaboos that
republicans love to throw out there is
some kind of you know they're this
barrier to progress in this country
regulations are strangling small
business here in the United States it's
the fault of these regulations that you
can't find a job it's because of these
regulations that the economy is is bad
it's the fault of these regulations for
everything under the Sun according to
the Republican Party this has been their
platform since I was born and today with
a republican-controlled Congress and
Senate and White House and Supreme Court
the assault on these life-saving
regulations has reached a peak the likes
of which we have not seen in this
country and here's the thing that
Republicans don't want to tell you these
are regulations that they're out there
fighting against we're all designed to
protect human life it's as simple as
that regulations exist because at one
point it was needed to save lives the
government the public saw a problem they
saw that you know what maybe if we had
hard hats or some kind of protective
head cover
for construction workers you know
falling tools or equipment wouldn't be
an instant death sentence for them so we
come up with regulations corporations
that dump their toxic wastes into our
lakes and streams and our aquifers they
pump it out into the air we have
regulations against that not because we
hate corporations not because we want to
punish corporations but because we have
to do it to save lives and these
companies have proven time and time
again that if we leave it up to them
they're not gonna do it when you give a
corporation the opportunity to do the
right thing on their own or to let it
slide and hope nobody notices nine times
out of ten at least they're gonna pick
the path of least resistance because it
doesn't cost them any money a lot of
corporations understand that you don't
get away with everything forever but
they build into their cost-benefit
analyses the amount of money that they
would potentially payout in a lawsuit
compared with the risk of financial risk
of compliance and oftentimes it's
cheaper to poison an entire community
and then pay out settlements in the form
of lawsuits and medical monitoring than
it is to comply with regulations but
since Donald Trump took office since the
Republican Congress and Senate were Ries
Warren in this past January again we're
talking about an entire establishment in
DC that's working overtime to give these
corporations everything they want by
repealing every single regulation that
they can get their hands on and again
they're doing this to save corporations
money and by saving corporations money
it puts human life American lives at
risk
that's all there is to it Republican
policy is designed to harm American
citizens to benefit American
corporations
that's what this entire fight about
regulations is all about
they love to point out the fact or they
call it effect that regulations are
killing small businesses small
businesses are closing down because
we've put these burdensome regulations
on them I challenge anyone to send me
definitive information of how any small
business in the United States was
strangled by regulations because small
businesses don't have to worry about
toxic waste your local pizzeria owned by
the guy down the street is not dumping
toxic waste into the water supply but
why are we trying to ease those
regulations that doesn't affect small
businesses like Republicans tell us they
do the the family that owns the little
boutique on the corner they're not
spewing carbon into the atmosphere yet
we're rolling back those regulations
because allegedly they hurt small
businesses these Republican talking
points when you put them to the test
when you compare them to the actual
outside world they don't hold up yet
there are too many people in this
country that buy into that and think you
know what they're right these
regulations are bad we don't need these
protections we don't need overtime rules
we don't need workplace safety
protections we don't need OSHA we don't
need the EPA or the FDA what we do every
one of those government organizations
exists to save American lives it's as
simple as that and any time we roll back
a regulation any time we try to cut
these agencies funding cut their
staffing we're doing it so that
corporations can pocket a little extra
money a year and so that American
citizens can live in constant fear that
their office building is not safe or
that the construction site they work at
is not safe or that the water they are
drinking is not say